قواته فاجنرت وسيطر على سوليدر وقصف مكثف
على خارقيف وازلنسكي يحذر من تحديد روسيه
قائد الاسطول الخامس يتهم ايران بالوقوف
خلف غالبيه المخاطر المحدقه في المنطقه
والتزويد روسيا بقدرات قتاليه
للتعاون لمعرفه التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
طب ثم طبت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره
اخباريه من العربيه البدايه من تطورات
الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت كيف الروسيا
استهدف مساء امس مدينه
قامت بها الى المدينه وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه
على البقاء في الملاجئ في ظل تجدد القصف
الروسي على المدينه
اعلنت قوته فوق الروسيه سيطرتها الكامله
على بلده سوليدار في دونيسك الاوكرانيه
وقالت انها ستعلن الاربعاء عن عدد الاسرى
الاوكرانيين من معركه سوليدار
واكد قائد قوات فاجنر لعدم مشاركه اي
وحدات غير مقاتل فاجنر في الهجوم على
سوريا
اعلن البنتاجون ان الولايات المتحده ستدرب
طواقيم عسكريه اوكرانيه في قاعده بولايه
اوكلاهما على طريقه استخدامه وصيانه
منظومه الدفاع الجوي المتقدمه باتريوت
التي توفرها واشنطن لكيف وقال الناطق باسم
المكتب الاعلامي للانتاج هنا الجنرالبات
رايدر قال للصحفيين ان تدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه على منظومه يبدا الاسبوع
المقبل في فورت سيل في ولايه اوكلاهما
ان التدريب سيشمل ما بين 90 الى 100 جندي
الاوكراني لتشغيل المنظومه الدفاعيه
وصيانتها والحفاظ عليها
خلال دوره تدريبيه يتوقع ان تستمر لاشهر
الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي بدوره قال ان بلاده بحاجه
شديده لمزيد من الامدادات امدادات الاسلحه
الحديثه من الغرب لان روسيا تحشد قواتها
من اجل مزيد من التصعيد واضاف زلنسكي ان
العالم الحر لديه كل ما هو ضروري لوقف
روسيا وعدوانها واحداث هزيمه تاريخيه بها
اشارت صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه عن مشاركه
كبيره للمواطنين الفنلنديين في مواقع
الكترونيه تتيح كتابه رسائل وتوقيعات على
قذائف المدافع الاوكرانيه المستخدمه في
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وذلك مقابله
مبالغه ماليه تتراوح ما بين 200$
200$ و500 دولار وتذهب هذه الاموال دعما
للقوات الاوكرانيه في مواجهه روسيا التي
تضغط بدورها بسلاح الطاقه على اوروبا
وبشكل كبير الافندالندا
اصوات المدافع الاوكرانيه المدعومه من
فنلندا في حربها مع روسيا ليست كافيه
للفنلنديين لابداء دعمهم في الصراع
الدائره
وسائلهم على قضاء في المدافع تسجل
استمراريه وتصميم لهذا الدعم منصه فنلنديه
غير ربحيه تدعى ساين ميروكي دوت كوم تعلن
السماحه لدعم القوات الاوكرانيه بالتوقيع
وكتابه رسائل على الذخائر الاوكرانيه ثم
اعاده نشرها في ما بعد
التوقيع مقابل الدعم المالي ما بين 200
دولار امريكي الى 500 قيمه لوضع اسماء
ورسائل الفلنديين على قضاء في المدفعيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ووفقا لصحيفه التايمز البريطانيه فان
المواقع الالكترونيه المشابهه والمتخصصه
بالتبرع لاوكرانيا جمعت مئات الالاف من
الدولارات منذ اطلاقها فيما تحظى فنلندا
من نصيب الاكبر من هذه التبرعات
قلق المواطنين الفنلنديين من ان تطال
بلادهم نيران الحرب الروسيه عكسته ارقام
اليها التايمز حيث دعى
58% من الفنلنديين الى رفع ميزانيه البلاد
العسكريه كما اعرب
85% عن قلقهم بشان تصعيد روسي المتزايد
تحرك فلنديين بالتبرع والتوقيع على القضاء
في الاوكرانيه يتزامنه مع مواجهتهم ازمه
طاقه فبعد ما اعتمدت فنلندا على ثلث
احتياجاتها من روسيا الان تقترب من الرقم
صفر الامر الذي يجعل تفسيرا لمواجهه
فرنديين للسقيع برسائل القذائف الاوكرانيه
اتهما قائد الاسطول الخامس للبحريه
الامريكيه الادميرال براد كوبر ايران
مباشره بالوقوف وراء غالبيه الهجمات في
المنطقه وقال كوبر خلال مؤتمر للبحريه في
واشنطن ان استخدام القدرات القتاليه خلال
الهجمات المتكرره في المنطقه تقوم بها
ايران مباشره او من خلال ميليشيتها في
الشرق الاوسط
ان المخاطر
المهديتها منذ شهرين مثلا كان هناك هجوم
بالمسيرات على سفينه تجاريه وفتحت فجوه في
جسم السفينه هذا الهجوم وصل الى الجسم
الداخلي للناقله وكان من الممكن ان يكون
الوضع ماسويه لكن من حسن الحظ ان لا
اصابات وقعت في صفوف البحر لكن الهجوم
يعكس استخدام ايران المتكرر والمتزايد
للقدرات القتاليه حيث تقوم بذلك مباشره او
عن طريق الميليشيات التابعه لها في الشرق
اوسط تشدر الاشاره الى ان هذه القدرات
تعطيها ايران لروسيا للقيام بهاجماتها على
اوكرانيا
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه انها لم
تستبعد فكرتها ادراج الاتحاد الاوروبي
الحرس الثوري الايراني على قوائم الارهاب
بعد يوم من قول المانيا ان التحرك سيكون
مهما ومنطقيا على الصعيد السياسي
وتدهورت العلاقات بين باريس وطهران في
الاشهر الماضيه في ظل تعثر جهود احياء
المحادثات النوويه التي تشارك فيها فرنسا
واعتقل الطيران سبعه مواطنين فرنسيين في
ظل انتقاد فرنسا لقمع ايران المتظاهرين في
الوقت الحالي
دعاء شخصيه اوروبيه حكومات الدول الغربيه
الى رفع مستوى الضغط على النظام الايراني
والانتقالي الى مرحله العزل الدبلوماسي
والاقتصادي التام من خلال سحب
الدبلوماسيين الاوروبيين من طهران وطرد
الدبلوماسيين الايرانيين من اوروبا
وامريكا
الطريق العملي لدعم 80 مليون ايراني
يتحدون المجازر التي يرتكبها النظام في
تظاهراتهم المتواصله منذ اربعه اشهر هو
عبر اتخاذ خطوات تؤكد الايرانيين اننا
نلعبهم وندعم ثورتهم من خلال سحب السفراء
الاوروبيين من طهران وطرد جميع السفراء
والدبلوماسيين الايرانيين من الاراضي
الاوروبيه
الشخصيات الاوربيه
الايرانيين عن قمع الاحتجاجات ورفضها
مقايضه
المقايضه الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه المعتقل
في بلجيكا على خلفيه مخططه فاشل ارهابي في
مقابل المواطن البلجيكيه الذي اختطفته
سلطات ايرانيه وحكمت عليه بالسجن لمده
اربعين عاما اذا حط بهاوتر
محاسبه المسؤولين الايرانيين الذين
انتهكوا حقوق الانسان وارتكبوا فضائح في
ايران لقد اعدموا اربعه من المحتاجين
احدهم اعدم شنقا وترك معلقا في اعلى
الرافعه وسط ساحه عامه تلك طبيعه النظام
في ايران لا يمكننا التسامح معه ولمجال
للتعامل الدبلوماسي لقد انتهى التعاون مع
التهران وفيما يتعلق بالمواطن البلجيكي
المحتجز في ايران اذا خضعنا للاهتزاز
الايراني وسامحنا بتبادل اسد الله اسد
الذي حاول قتلنا فاننا سنشجع النظام
الايراني على اختطاف المزيد من الرهائن
قال وزير الاعلام اليمني معمر
البحريه اعتراض سفينه ايرانيه تحمل اسلحه
للحوثيين يؤكدما والصفه بتصعيد نظامهران
عملياته تهريب الاسلحه للجماعات للجماعه
في انتهاكنسافر للقواني الدوليه واضاف
الوزير ان تسعد ايران هذه العمليات عمليات
تهريب الاسلحه ومكونات الصواريخ والطائرات
المسيره
وارسالها للحوثيين منذ انتهاء الهدنه
الامميه يؤكد دورها في تعويض جهود الهدنه
هكذا الرئيس الامريكي جوبيد ان انه لا
يعرفه مضمون الوثائق السريه التي وجدت في
مكتبه للدراسات وتعود لفتره عمله نائبا
للرئيس الاسبق باراك اوباما
تيتو مواعيد
السريه على محمل الجد لقد ابلغت بما تم
العثور عليه وفوجئت عندما علمت ان وثائق
متعلقه بالحكومه نقلت الى ذلك المكتب لكني
لا اعرف ما تحتويه تلك الوثائق لقد سلمت
الصناديق الى الارشيف ونحن نتعاون بشكل
كامل وامنوا ان تنتهي مراجعه الوثائق
قريبا وسيكون هناك المزيد من التفاصيل في
ذلك الوقت
في هذا المبنى في الطابق السادس عثر على
وثائق التقريبا 10 صنفت بانها وثائق سريه
تابعه للرئيس بيضين عندما كان يشغل منصب
نائبا رئيس طبعا هذا سبب احراج كبير للبيت
الابيض لانه اتهم بالزواجيه المعايير
بالمقارنه مما حدث مع الرئيس ترامب الذي
حقق الاف بي اي في الوثائق التي وجدت في
مره لارجو لكن البعض يقول بانه لا مقارنه
اولا البيت الابيض اعرب عن تعاونه مع طبعا
مكتب التحقيق الفيدرالي وقال بانه يريد ان
يعيد كل هذه الوثائق الى الارشيف الوطني
وان هذه الوثائق لا تحمل مثلا اسرار نوويه
او غيرها لكن بغض النظر رئيس مجلس النواب
كيف مقاسي قال بان الامر مقلق للغايه وهذا
طبعا سيسبب احراج كبير للبيت الابيض وقد
يؤثر على مستقبل الرئيس السيسي
[موسيقى]
صوت الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب الامريكي
على انشاء لجنه فرعيه مختاره بشان ما يسمى
بتسليح الحكومه الفيدراليه ويرى خبراء ان
اللجنه الفرعيه الجديده تستهدف التحقيقات
الجاريه في وزاره العدل ومكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي بشان الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب
تشكيل مجلس النواب الامريكي لجنه قضائيه
فرعيه للتحقيق بما يسمى بتسليح الحكومه
الفدراليه خطوه جديده نحو احتدام الصراع
بين الجمهوريين واداره ايضا فمهام اللجنه
الفرعيه ستشمل وفقه مراقبين مراجعه
التحقيقات مع الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
والخوض في القضايا القانونيه التي تدور
حوله وسيكون لديها سلطه الاشراف على
التحقيقات الجنائيه الجاريه كما يمكنها
الوصول الى نفس المعلومات التي تطلع عليها
لجنه الاستخبارات
في الاشراف على الاداره هذا من واجباتنا
لقد تم اهمالها خلال العامين الماضين
سنجري اشراف قويا للتاكد من ان اموال
دافعين الضرائب انفقت بشكل صحيح وللتخلص
من الهدر والاحتيال وسوء المعامله التي
رايناها في الحكومه من المجموعات الحكوميه
كما ستحقق اللجنه الفرعيه التي سيراسها
جيم جوردن المقرب من ترامب في الاتصالات
بين شركات التكنولوجيا الكبرى واداره ايضا
للضغط على المحافظين على الانترنت
من الانتخابيه وتشكيل هذه اللجنه الفرعيه
هي احدى هذه الوعوده وواحده من اوائل
المواجهات مع الديمقراطيين خلال العامين
المقبلين
يعتبرون ان تشكيلها لجنه الفرعيه احد
التنازلات التي قدمها رئيس المجلس كيف
نقارتي ليمنينا جمهورينا للفوز بمطرقه
المجلس معتبرين ان ذلك ليس من مصلحه
مع قياده من جانب الاغلبيه من مصلحتنا
التاكد من اننا نمثل دور الكونجرس والشعب
الامريكي وان جمهوريين ليس لديهم فرصه خلف
الابواب المغلقه لاضافه نظريات المؤامرات
هذه
وفيما يتهم الجمهوريون الديمقراطيين بما
يسمى بتسليح الحكومه الفيدراليه
يردمقراطيون ان هذه اللجنه الفرعيه
الجديده هي السلاح نفسه حسين الروض
العربيه واشنطن
نشرتنا المستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
الشرطه البريطانيه تحقق بطرد مشبوه ملوث
باليورانيوم عثر عليه في مطره
حياكم الله اعلن وزير الداخليه التركيه
سليمان سولو ان بلاده تسلمت من بلغاريا
المدعو هزني الذي هرب هرب بلال حسان مخطط
تفجير شارع الاستقلال وسط اسطنبول واضاف
سويله ان تسليما بالغاليه جاء بعد تحديد
الامن التركي ما كانه في البلد الجار وتمت
عمليه التسليم مساء امس الثلاثاء في ولايه
ادنى شمال غربيه تركيا
بدات قواته التجاريه التي خاضت حربا
استمرت عاما عامين ضد الحكومه الاتحاديه
الاثيوبيه بدات تسليم اسلحه ثقيله للجيش
الوطني في اطار عمليه سلام يقودها الاتحاد
الافريقي
واشرف على التسليم فريقه مراقبه يتالف من
اعضاء من الجانبين والهيئه الحكوميه
للتنميه لدول الشرق افريقيا السلام
فتحت شرطه ومكافحه الارهاب البريطانيه
تحقيقا بشان ضبط ماده الملوثه باليورانيوم
بمطره هيثرو في التاسع والعشرين من ديسمبر
الماضي
وقال التقرير نقلا عن قياده الشرطه في
لندن ان الحزمه من الماده الملوثه صغيره
وجرى فحصها من قبل الخبراء وقالوا انها لا
تشكل اي تهديد على حياه الناس
بعد الضجه الكبيره التي اثارتها مقابلاته
التلفزيون يا خلال الايام الاخيره وبعد
تسريبات المثيره للجدل بشان محتواه صدر
الثلاثاء كتاب الامير هاري الذي يتحدث فيه
عن حياته وعن الخلافات داخل العائله
الملكيه البريطانيه في حين تصدر الكتاب
قائمه مبيعات الكتب على موقع شركه امازون
في بريطانيا التي شهدت المكتبات فيها
اقبالا من المواطنين الذين تفاوضت مواقفهم
من الكتاب ومن الامير
اخيرا كتاب سيره الامير هاري على رفوف
المكتبات والمتاجر صار في متناول محبي
الامير وكاريه على السواق لتصفح الصفحات
ال 416 وما تحتويه من فيض من التفاصيل
المثيره عن حياته وعن الخلافات داخل
عائلته من كشفه عن مشاجره مع اخيه وليام
وصولا الى اعترافه بقتل 25 مقاتلا في
طالبان وكلامه عن طاعه المخدرات كلها امور
اثارت ردود فعل عديده وستترك بلا شك اثرا
على مبيعات الكتاب وشعبيه الامير
اشتريت الكتاب لانني اريد ان اكون جزءا من
التاريخ ولمعرفتي ما جرى في القصر خصوصا
الامور التي لم نسمع عنها من قبل وكيف
تصرفت الصحافه مع هاري
لترويج كتابه وما زعم مثيره طالت افراد
العائله الملكيه صدمت متابع الامير
وعائلته من جهه ومؤيد العائله المالكه من
جهه اخرى وان كانت الغالبيه ترى ضروره
ابقاء اسرار العائله الملكيه ومشاكل
اعضائها حديثه القصر لن اقتني الكتاب
لاننا قضينا وقتا كافيا للحديث عن هذا
الموضوع وحصل على ما يكفي من الدعايه ولا
اظن ان من المنطقي شراء الكتاب
وليس لدي شيء ضد الكتاب اتعاطف مع الامير
لكن معه انه يستحق اضاعه وقتي لقراءته
سجن الامير هاري الملايين من الجنيهات من
مبيعات الكتاب وسيخص جزء منها لمنظمه
خيريه اسسها لمساعده الاطفال المصابين
بفيروس نقص المناعه في افريقيا
يحتل كتابه مذكرات الامير هاري المرتبه
الاولى في قوائم مبيعات الكتب على موقع
امازون ويتوقعوا ان يحضر الكتابه باقبال
كبير في المكتبات بعد حمله تسويقيه منذ
الاعلامي عن نشر سيرته الذاتيه
كعادتها التزمت العائله الملكيه السمطه
ولم تعلق على مزاعم الكتاب تركه الكلام
الهاري اللي يحكموا على تداعيات اصداره
على المدى الطويل مصطفى زاروه العربيه
لندن
الله يشفيه
غالبيه
البريطانيين المعتدين على العائله الملكه
يدركون انه من وقت الى اخر يدخل احد بينهم
لا يستحق مكانته لكن هذا لا يعني ان اعضاء
العائله الاخرين غير جديرين بالاحترام يجب
ان نتجاهل هريره
التي نريد ان نكتب او نتحدث عنها
وصل الى هذه المرحله هذا سيء له
عوامل طبعا
ذلك للعائله الملكيه امر سيء يجب ان يبقى
ذلك امرا خاصا وخلف الابواب المغلقه اعتقد
انه سيؤدي الى مزيد من الدعم للعائله
الملكيه لكن هاري سيخسر ذلك الدعم الناس
تنظر اليه على انه طعنهم في الظهر
سيثير ضجه رغم اننا اطلعنا على افضل ما
فيه من خلال تسريبات الصحافه وما قاله
هاري مؤخرا للتمهيد للكتاب لا اعتقد شخصيا
انني ساجد شيئا جديدا فيه لكنني متاكده
انك اذا كنت مؤيدا للعائله اولهاري ستجد
ضالتك فيها
بعد ثلاث سنوات تقريبا من عمليه الهضم
منتظمه تقوم بها الصين في المياه والمجال
الجويه
للجزيره استعدادا الى اكثر من 20 دينار
ظهرت جميعها بالمحصله خسائر بالغه بالعديد
والعتاد لطرفي السرعه
معركه دون رابح ما خساره وزنه على الجهتين
هذا ما اظهرته سيناريوهات متعدده تحاكي
غزوه صينيا لتايوان الجزيره التي تتمتع
بحكم ذاتي وتطالب الصين باستعادتها بالقوه
اللازمه الامر 24 سيناري واجرهم مركز
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه والدوليه في واشنطن
استبعد جميعها خروج الصين منتصره منه هكذا
حربه بل دفعها اثمانا هائله وبحسب
المحاكاه الحرب ستترك البحريه الصينيه في
حاله من الفوضى وتحطم جوهر قوتها البريه
والبحريه وستفقد الصين 255 طائره مقاتله
238 سفينه كبيره وفقا تقرير
خسارتها تمتد لقواتها مع توقعاته بمقتل
حوالي 10,000 من جنودها واسرع عشرات
الالاف وفي خانه المدافعين عن تايوان تقف
كل من الولايات المتحده واليابان البلدان
سيخسران عشرات السفن الحربيه ومئات
الطائرات المقاتله و خسائر بشريه بالالاف
فمعظم السيناريوهات تتوقع ان تفقد البحريه
الامريكيه حاملتي طائرات وما بين عشره الى
20 سفينه مقاتله كبيره فيما تقول التوقعات
ان نحو ثلاثه الاف ومئتاجين امريكيه
سيلقون مصرعهم خلال ثلاثه اسابيع من
القتال اي نحو نصف ما خسرته في عقدين من
القتال في العراق وافغانستان
اليابان ايضا خزائرها ليست بقليله وفق
المحاكاه اكثر من 100 طائره مقاتله و 26
سفينه حربيه حاله شلل ستعانيها البلدان
الثلاثه في حال حدوث الغزو واسع النطاق
للجزيره البالغ عدد سكانها 24 مليون نسمه
لكنه مستبعده وفقا خبراء
فرغ ما قيامها بعمليات توغل منتظمه في
المياه والمجال الجوي قرب طيوان الا ان
بكين لن تخاطر بهكذا مناوره معدومه
النتائج وتضر اقتصادها بشكل هائل
وقذف مكثف على خارقيفه
قائد الاسطول الخامس
غالبيه المخاطر المحرقه في المنطقه وتزويد
روسيا بقدرات قتاليه
لمعرفه التفاصيل
شكرا لكم لطيب المتابعه القاكم بعد دقائق
[موسيقى]